an leute glaubt nicht was den hamster
kaufen wir heute machen wir kaufen milch
für den ganzen sommer in ihrer besten
verpackungen der mit in form einer neuen
mächtigen richtig aufgeregt weil ich mir
das schon so lange wünsche und jetzt
seien ein trauriger anlass gekommen
nämlich meine alte anna meine geliebte
vor als siege die ist schon richtig
schwach auf den beinen und krank der
natur sind schon 14 jahre alt und bricht
im moment immer wieder zusammen und ich
habe im moment nur zwei ziegen und wenn
die eine stirbt ist die andere alleine
und deswegen nehme ich das zum anlass um
jetzt endlich eine neue mächtige zu
kaufen die eine einzige mit einem
kleinen zicklein es gerade mal drei
wochen alt und unglaublich niedlich und
lustigerweise ist die frau verdächtigt
ihn jetzt kaufe auch eine blockieren
die hatte für mich dann hat meine
emailadresse erkannt und es auch ganz
lustig dass wir uns jetzt so sehen auch
wenn gerade kontaktsperre ist so dass
wir uns nicht besonders nahe kommen
natürlich und aufpassen dass alles
corona sicher abläuft aber ich bin
unglaublich aufgeregt und freue mich
super dass wir jetzt schaffen gehen
[Musik]
jetzt gab es auch schon gewechselt weil
das hier hast du tolle gitterstangen so
dass man mit dem auto hier unseren
wunderbaren transportieren kann
und jetzt geht's richtig
[Musik]
ihr müsst auch mal hinten legen so viel
zu wenig aufregende vorbehalten
[Musik]
er bittet zum 1 selbst meine ziele nicht
so anfahren
[Musik]
wir sind ganz angekommen ist schon ganz
ganz dunkel
ich hab grad nochmal bottich mit heu
geholt und mit wissen im stall noch ein
bisschen gemütlicher ein strahlen können
und dann laden wir die ziegen gleich
ausdrucken yahoo sie versteht es gar
nicht was hier los ist mitten in der
nacht
da springen sie hoffentlich werdet ihr
bald freunde sein so süß so niedlich du
bist so wild managen sind da können die
gestern noch im dunkeln ausgeladen es
gab erst mal eine kleine keilerei hier
das ist immer ganz normal wenn neue
ziegen in die herde kommen ist die
anderen erst zeigen müssen keinen fall
der neue chef
aber mittlerweile ist alles ganz
friedlich
und ja sie sind wunderschön
gerade kleine lernens hat noch keinen
namen
es ist am 8 märz also am weltfrauentag
geboren
es braucht also dringend einen
feministischen starken frauen nahmen
also wenn ihr ideen habt für einen namen
für das kleine zicklein dann schreibt
sie gerne weil unten in die kommentare
ich bin so glücklich dass ich endlich
eine neue milchziegen aber es wird
natürlich noch dauern bis sich die
melden kann im moment wirkt die ganze
mich erstmal das zicklein in ein paar
wochen können wir die dann anfangen
langsam anzumerken und weiterhin das
züglein noch dran lassen
und wenn es dann ganz abgestellt ist
dann bekommen wir die milch ganz für uns
die hat jetzt das erste lämmchen also
dass das heute immer noch relativ klein
und es gibt die ziege gibt auch noch
nicht so super viel milch aber ich denke
das wird eine super sache sein ich
versuche auch unsere rosi anzumerken
jetzt wo die auf dem grünen frischen
gras stehen da kann es sein dass sie
wieder auf und haben wir das mit unserer
alten ziegel immer jeden frühling
gemacht ist sie dann einfach sobald das
frische gras da war so beides wieder
gutes futter gab auf geäußert hat und
wie die dann einfach weiter melden
konnten ohne dass 70 dann bekommen hat
wenn alles gut geht haben wir diesen
sommer wieder zwei milchziegen das ist
genau das was ich mir wünsche und wie
wir unsere familie super mit
milchprodukten selbst versorgen können
so sieht das schon ganz ganz friedlich
aus mittlerweile wo sie da hinten die
braune die muss ich schon immer noch mal
ein bisschen als chef auf ihren aber es
wird schon den ganz harmonisches bild
meistens die altana dies halt da auch
ganz gut auf den beinen
vorgestern sah sie noch so aus als ob
sie es keinen weiteren tag packen würde
habe ich sie hier gefunden da lag sie
auf dem rücken und ist nicht mehr
hochgekommen und heute läuft sie
wiederum jetzt bin nichts mehr was ist
das glaube ich mit natur sind gute und
es gibt schlechte tage wie schön der
seite ein guter lage
[Musik]
nein zu machen
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie viel zeit uns
die selbstversorgung mit den ganzen
tieren und dem garten insgesamt kostet
dann schon gerne mal da drüben vorbei in
dem video erzähle ich euch das nämlich
da unten findet ihr auch noch ein
spannendes video vielleicht sehen wir
uns ja da gleich wieder biss dann
macht's gut
[Musik]